It's time for the Final Five.
(audience applauding)
All right.
Scarlett, what's your most irrational fear?
My most irrational fear?
Well, I don't know.
I used to be like, I'm never gonna work again.
I would finish a job and then be like, that's it.
Well, I had a good run and I'm never gonna work again.
So, yes.
That's a good one.
It's bad, it's not good.
No, but it's understandable and relatable.
Okay, if you could see into the future,
what would you want to know?
I would want to know if Trump is gonna run again.
I just want to know, so I can be prepared.
I'm gonna bet yes.
I feel like that's probably gonna happen.
No.
Well.
I don't know if I can handle it.
I just don't know.
Sorry, I know this is like, a divisive topic.
You would like to mentally prepare yourself.
I need to be mentally prepared, that's all.
That's all I'll say.
All right, I get that.
Okay, what is something that you hope your kids
never find out about you?
I'm supposed to say that?
Oh yeah, that does defeat the purpose.
I'm trying to think what would I
not want my kids to find out about?
(Drew burps)
I'm sorry, I ate a ton of bugs earlier.
That was so nasty.
I cannot.
Oh my gosh, it was actually making me sick
watching you do that.
I have to tell you, they were delicious.
They needed a little salt.
Other than that, they were great.
There is no possible way I could do that.
They were really good, actually.
No, no, they weren't.
I swear, I swear.
I would eat 'em on a salad.
Crunch, crunch.
No.
Would you?
Yes, I think I would.
Ugh, no, I can't.
Okay, what is something your kids-
Oh, you know what I-
Well, I don't know.
My daughter may have asked me this before.
I used to smoke when I was younger,
and I'm so like, ashamed.
I just don't want her to ever think
that I ever thought it was cool,
'cause she can never, ever, ever smoke.
'Cause that's what you do,
you forbid your kids from doing things
and then they don't do them.
So, yeah.
I just hope she never kind of figures that out.
All right, when are you the most competitive?
I am the most when I'm playing backgammon.
It's great, I love backgammon.
So Colin and I started playing backgammon
a couple of years ago.
Somebody had given us a board like,
one of our checker boards or something was like,
also a backgammon board.
Like, I've always wanted to know how you play this game.
It's pretty easy to learn it.
And Colin annoyingly wins-
He wins at everything and it's so annoying.
Anyway, it's just like,
he'll last minute like, roll a bunch of doubles,
and you're like, why?
There's no way, like how is this happening?
He's so lucky.
But he also has been playing it on his phone
and it's like, that's not fair, that's cheating.
He's picking up all these like,
tools that he would never otherwise have
because he's like, playing on his phone.
I don't like it.
Hm.
Makes me want to like, find a backgammon champion
and like, get them to you secretly
so you could like, brush up on tips.
We'll talk.
Text you later.
Okay, last question.
Is it true that you can cry on command?
I could try.
I probably could-ish, yeah.
Okay, want to try?
Yeah.
(Drew sighs)
(audience laughing)
You're going to a dark place.
It's true, I only ever cry
when I start talking about like, my daughters, you know?
Okay, so you're gonna go there.
I'm gonna go there.
Okay.
Like, I didn't think that I could-
I didn't think that I would ever have the opportunity
to have the experience in life that I didn't have
with my mom, you know?
And it really just messes me up and it's like a chance
to get things, you know, not right,
'cause they were never wrong.
I loved my childhood.
Wouldn't change it for a thing.
But it's like, all of a sudden,
I just have this magical ability to-
I'm still thinking about you.
I'm like, I'm half there, but I'm half paying attention.
Oh my god, there goes the roll!
The tear came out.
It came out.
You win.
You win!
(audience applauding)
Full tear.
Full tear out the eye.
(Scarlett speaking indistinctly)
No, but you had them rolling out.
I was on the surface 'cause I'm half in,
like half paying attention.
Nicely done, Johansson.
Got the roll.
(audience applauding)
Anybody tuning in right now is gonna be like,
these people are sociopaths.
That's every day on this show.
We like to be weird and have fun and get deep.
It's such a great show, I am so excited for you.
Like, you're where you're supposed to be.
It's just wonderful.
(audience applauding)
I will say, in all sincerity,
I almost cried when you came out 'cause I was like,
proud to show you like, what we've been doing here.
(upbeat music)